Journalist Friday Olokor is getting ready
for an historic moment: Nigeria’s first-ever
presidential debate, broadcast live on all
major channels across the country.
But minutes before the start, speculation
is building.
Will the president himself show up?
"It has never happened that an incumbent will
come and appear at a live debate.
It has never happened.
But if President Muhammadu Buhari appears
for this debate, he will make history and
will enter into the nation's annals of positive
politics."
The event venue is filling up – but no sign
of Buhari.
Organizers say he promised to be here.
Atiku Abubakar, presidential candidate for
Nigeria's biggest opposition party, the PDP,
has already arrived – but now refuses
to go on stage.
We came here for a Presidential debate, not
a candidacy debate, and I, Atiku Abubakar
cannot challenge or question an administration
where the man at the helm of the affairs of
the nation is not present to defend himself
or his policies.
So, the podiums remain empty.
The PDP and Buhari's APC party are the two
biggest parties in Nigeria.
They're also the only democratic parties to
ever rule the country.
"They have just simply announced their exit
from governance."
"Pride always comes before the fall.
And every time you believe that you have no
need to tell the people what you are going
to do – it means that you are not there
to serve them in the first place."
President Buhari is not known for being a
talented speaker.
The 75-year old has also suffered from health
problems over the last few years.
Many Nigerians believe he dodged the debate
after an embarassing performance at his last
live appearance at a town hall meeting on
Wednesday.
There, he appeared anxious and struggled to
answer questions.
"Well, uh.
I honestly cannot remember.
Uh."
At the end of the presidential debate, Friday
Olokor is satisfied – despite the limited
attendance.
The other candidates did a good job, the journalist
says, talking about the burning topics in
Nigeria: education, the struggling economy,
and security.
Maybe, Olokor says, some of Nigeria's poltiical
underdogs might have a real chance now.